we'll get a real thoughts and our
battery only has like 24 minutes so we
got a broster short don't blame me blame
him yeah it's totally my fault
let's set it head lice forty minutes ago
and you know and now it's like twenty
four it's like bah-bah-bah
okay so we're gonna talk about what is
currently our most watched video by hits
in terms of YouTube but right it's gonna
get passed soon by it but but still the
most watch top of Sharkboy and Lavagirl
as well as like just Robert Rodriguez
films kind of in general pinky how about
we give that a Miss no no I think we can
talk about that cuz i I love Robert
Rodriguez like I really dig the fact
this is like a filmmakers filmmaker he
just sort of does everything by himself
you know we make fun in the review and
like man I have no problem with Robert
Robert he start there's a lot of shit
but I mean he's done a lot of good stuff
- yeah it's like a bear Mick but even
like it's one of those things where it's
like even way makes shit it's like if
you did like everything how you even got
this shit is amazing yeah okay like you
confuse it with Spy Kids 3 yeah yeah
we're not tired I love a girl is like
I'm not making this up like here's the
problem you do so many films we've been
doing this what 10 years now nearly I
forget some of the ones we've reviewed
like and that's its own bed just that
one ear and out the other
yeah see I still remember it because
this is the one that like one of his
kids quote-unquote wrote I'm sure like
he went off of his stories or something
like that and it's one of those things
where it's like though that's so cute
and that's so loving but dammit that's a
sell movies on the dream does this have
a tornado in it and yeah okay I'm
halfway made of sharks and a girl made
my mom literally having like acid
flashbacks I've just flashes like and
and the evil kid remember with the Cape
it's like who dare come here was it
Linus and - that's right oh yeah it's
just hands down the best part of okay
that's all I remember
okay good luck I'm not sure what the
hell to talk about it's we also are the
effects that are you know very you know
90s commercial ask like it's just
obviously you know sir this very basic
dream is
yeah I mean so so that's the thing I
know what you would expect it's one of
those things where it's like on the one
hand you gotta kind of admire this this
guy's just doing everything he just
pretty much gives a gift to his kid you
know in terms of stories into a movie
and sees if he can make money on it -
which apparently it is
I'm sure made money but there's a reason
like you don't just be like hey I'm
gonna do this movie that my kid coughed
up in a bad dream one night like it yeah
if you listen to most like kids are
really managers have been cool and like
we celebrate the imagination of children
but a lot of it is just bad shit um like
I'm sorry like sometimes like I'll I'll
listen to my niece talk and like she'll
have cool ideas of Wonders and other
times you're just listening and you're
just like wow that's just insane yeah
that's cool that's what kids are about
it's just crazy but I wouldn't make a
movie on it it's kind of finding that
balance between like just pure
imagination do whatever you want and
kind of a discipline to give it
structure and today the pigs are the it
and you need like the logos and the
pathos - kind of yeah you need something
reel it in and stuff yeah and what I
remember about this movie I marry the
kid from Twilight is in it and he's he's
legit actually kind of good and then the
kid that play Linus I thought was legit
really come on yeah Jacob he's Sharkboy
I don't remember any like I literally
like no I was sober when we did this up
in heaven do we black it out was it just
like what kangaroo jazz everything I
remember like seeing it but but I know
you're talking about blends in with his
other a kind of kid kids films cuz
they're all kids 3 is my problem
i am i confusing it with that well okay
so you saw the first by kids right i
actually i think i'd you set you down by
kids for what it is is actually pretty
good I think actually set you down I'm
like look you just kind of gotta watch
this and you're like spiky kids I'm like
trust me it's not it's got my shit but
it's like and you're like what you think
once I kung fu panda which I saw in your
recommendation and it's not as good as
come from Panda but
and I came out of spite kids is like you
know what that was cute I mean there was
really imagine yeah we ended it out
there clearly aimed at kids so it got a
little bit more of a pass or I'm like
okay this isn't a Pixar film which like
votes for the adults and the kids is
like no you really were aiming this at
kids but it was like I could see how a
kid would love it but there's also legit
intent like in the beginning around we
saw the beginning and we just said this
movie is amazing with the backstory and
stuff and then when the kids come in
it's like okay let's is this cat film
okay but what the fuck this there was a
minute there was a lot of so great and
then like the weird stuff with Alan
Cumming and everything and there's some
freaking Tweenies Shalhoub and then yeah
yeah and the weird fungus and the Alan
Cumming and I remember yeah like and
then I tell you what happened in Spy
Kids 2 I kind of remember Spy Kids 3
because I'm confusing it which are well
and it seemed to go from like you know
cuz I don't even think he did kids films
before and I think he can't thought well
I got a crazy ass imagination and so do
my kids you know we can sort have fun
combine these things in me real fast it
was like this huge hit like you know
they made two sequels out of his huge
hit and then I think he just maybe he
thought like he found his calling and
like his second calling like kids films
I can do this and they're actually kind
of easy and fun I can work with kids and
this is really cool and they didn't
always turn out that great movies but it
still has a following here's my problem
with them it it just feels like
something that Robert Rodriguez should
have shown is like a home movie like a
fan like get the family together it's
like a look at what the kids and I did
like that's what it needs to be you
don't need to go to cinema and see that
and Ike I like Sharkboy and Lavagirl
like I just kind of felt like if you're
a parent I hope you just drop your kids
off to that one like I'll see you in an
hour and a half you know I can't
remember it especially there's like one
scene where they're trying to do like
commentary I'm like the kids connection
to his parents and like he sees them as
these big monsters wearing like cookie
hats and stuff and they get along and
it's like they don't even talk they just
get along music oh that's nice is that
what you wish your parents did yeah and
that's it and I feel like man like just
move over where the wild things are
that's the commentary on a kid psyche
okay
connecting to their parents in their
world and everything and I just feel
what a shame when like you see something
like that you see something that does do
it so well like wait while things are
and then something like that which is
clearly like oh that's like this well of
course it is what else this one didn't
have Ricardo Montalban in a rocket
powered wheelchair right again that's
three cut damage or maybe that's too
goddamn it wait what did Sylvester
Stallone name is three Oh goddamn it
Iceman that line there's some reason
would you say sharp we love a girl they
keep going to Spy Kids 3 there they
aren't your only similar think the same
visual look at everything
I'll have you know though that like the
kid who played lion does he actually
contacted me and he said did I love your
review thank you for getting you know
the complements and stuff like that even
though I'm like yeah no you're actually
kind of the best part you were so
undertaking there's a lot of kid actors
that like when they're hammy and over
the top I'm just like god they so made
this movie like yeah I know it doesn't
always work you always you know I'm not
gonna name names it depends on the
movement yeah but it depends on the
movie the tone but there's just some kid
actors like that that weird kid from
that Care Bears sequel we reviewed weird
voice like I love that like it's I don't
know if this is some about it and of
course Lucas who apparently couldn't
keep his power buff himself yeah like
that was another one where it's like
that kid was so over the top yeah I feel
like if you put that performance like in
a much more serious kids filled like it
wouldn't work but in sharpen operators
performance by a ten-year-old ever I
want to say would be like Jack Black in
neverending story three but no no he was
on but but you know stuff like that
that's kind of like a passionate like
it's throwing it all into it uh and then
it's weird cuz like I say with the
exception of Sharkboy your kid actors I
can't explain those count with the spike
kids films - they're just a little odd
remember them yeah like they're not all
for anything hmm bourbon I can't
firstly two kids from Spy Kids and then
I think they ditch the girl eventually
in the third a third
know that those plot is to get her back
Oh to get her back okay but they they
ditched her like obviously you see
either she thought she
- good for these movies are they they
didn't bring her back but oh yeah oh
yeah that's a good those are that I
don't remember who replaced her I don't
I don't even know of anyone Debbie was
just a boy but but yeah it's one of
those things where it's like again cuz
these are made so fast you do kind of
wonder if for every guess it's like okay
we have no child labor laws we have no
budget no time great let's just go on to
the next one stuff like that and you
kind of just got a hope it'll come
together and editing and again the first
five kids I think it did and then second
was we're starting to fall apart third
one is not good and then we get Sharkboy
and Lavagirl just the epitome of
craziness and insanity um but I don't
know if there's even like when they try
to put like some of these rules in or
like they try to limit it a little bit
it's I'd actually like more if the
imagination did just explode instead of
trying to have like well here's the
story here's the plot here's the like if
it was something like spirited away
where it's just like no she's in a bath
house that's it everything else is just
her experience in that weird-ass bath
house and her trying to get out or
something like that it didn't seem like
there she was as a slave until she died
you know a few a few rules in terms of
how the world work with the bad tokens
and like all the little gears and stuff
like that so I'm not gonna lie you this
is just gibberish to me because it's
like I don't remember what the hell
and we'll the rules did they have rules
in Sharkboy and Lavagirl I'm not joking
I don't remember goddamn thing about
this well fine I'll remember it so you
don't have to go for it dudes
I feel terrible like if you had told me
ahead of time I would have rewatched it
maybe maybe we need to stop doing that
but um yeah it's I know but you thought
in general with just Robert Rodriguez
and stuff like that idea of sort of
doing the kids films like it's a good
idea he just has to execute he did early
on I don't know if it was you know what
is I feel like they became more and more
like garage projects like the second he
got out of the idea of like oh I I don't
have to work with Hollywood I can make
my own things in my garage they got
worse and worse and worse and I'm like
no I think you needed I know you hate
Holly I'm like we all hate Holly when
the studio's like but I think they gave
you the
the money the preparation - coughs
something out with a little more effort
than whatever Shark Boy and Lava well
know says there's a balance - you need
you know they say you can actually
become more creative in your limitations
and what do you have somebody's saying
no you can't do this why because X Y Z
you know it's and you know Damelin
sometimes they give it away ahem well
the studio would have sent that script
back like we have concerns yeah notes
things that would have gotten changed
yeah but at the same time there's like
great stories that could be told and now
we hear how many times the studio
destroys Andy as well so somewhere
there's a balance this is not one of
them though no this is one that really
need to be reeled in but at the same
time I mean I guess like like any
entertainer it's one of those things
where you kind of go like but you know
he's making some he loves and kids
loving clearly has an audience you know
so it's one of those things but I think
we can't get into this stuff like oh why
why because you see there's legit talent
with this dude and he's made these
really cool different stylistic news
then why there's such a huge like upward
light we kept getting requests for this
and I just remember looking I'm just
like Sharkboy and Lavagirl ya care I
just assumed people grew up with it and
they didn't know what to think of it
yeah cuz I just was just like it it's a
movie that looks like it's aimed at
four-year-olds who gives a crap like but
apparently it's got this huge like no
you don't get a man movie scarred me I'm
like well it is so friggin weird like
some of the stuff so yeah so odd I mean
I guess I can't imagine being 7 and
being dumped into that film you know
what it is it's weird but it's kind of
awkwardly we're weird my beard films I
think that's what kind of gifts under
people's skin sometimes it's like
something can be weird like Return to Oz
but awesome it's amazing it's creepy
returned Oz of which it couldn't move
yeah and it's good something like this
you know it's weird but also awkward and
it holds on shots and weird facial
expressions for a long time and it
doesn't feel like oh I'm getting sucked
into the weirdness is that your being
weirded out by the weirdness and not
having fun with it as much but there's
also a lot of people that really really
got into it and really enjoyed it
I don't think trying to think back on
the things I enjoyed as a kid I don't
think I would have liked it and if I
were 7 years old I'm like I said I don't
know may generally
still liked movies with a kind of plot
to know like you know it's like you've
the chipmunk adventure there was still a
plot a risk I would you react so I yeah
I'm trying to give all the weird things
I saw as a kid if I would have liked
this I'm like I don't think so
even something like Alice in Wonderland
like even though it's like it's blurry
just start going through this place and
discovering these weird things they're
still like kind of that threat there's
something a little messin about it even
the background is always black it's
always there are narrative there is like
a hook of you know I got lost in this
place I gotta get out chase the white
rabbit hmm and then everything tries to
kill her yeah like I can't remember what
the hell the plot to Sharkboy and
Lavagirl was yeah like just what was it
goes to Al and Linus were they trying to
get somebody back with but see that's my
kids 3 just keep going back to fight to
what happens because Sharkboy and
Lavagirl slashed by kids 3 but no it's
one of those things where it's like on
the one hand I really want like someone
like Rodriguez to keep exploring so
these weird crazy avenues without studio
your interference but then on the other
hand it's like I wanted to make good
stuff too I wanted to make something
that'll expand the imagination for a lot
of people and sometimes expanding the
imagination can come from limitations
and he has limitations in terms of like
budget and stuff like that obviously but
you know he's doing a lot of it himself
here's the pride and maybe this is part
of the problem the the ambition versus
the budget on that mm-hmm
cuz this is from the get-go was so fake
and I'm like why don't you scale your
damn movie back if it's gonna look that
bad like what and even like these sort
of and I get it I'm doing it on a garage
machine then don't do it or come up with
an excuse I'd do something like it just
that I just looked at it was just here's
the thing with like okay Sin City
low-budget movie clearly but the style
is so distinct and so interesting it's
you don't swallow that on the TV night
what really works for something like
dial no sharp or no I mean it's bright
it's colorful it's like a 90s commercial
but it's one of those things where it's
like for that to really feel like
whimsical and grand
big and cool you need something that
looks more like it's really there yeah I
think you can still be frightened
colorful but clearly those backgrounds
aren't there clearly this lands 1990s
commercial like it's just this is
something bland about it
like I I don't know I just nothing
sticks out you know you know there was
no discipline to obtain before you even
knew what you had you have packaged it
and handed it and then slapped it on
plastic lunch boxes and now you're gonna
sell you're selling it you're selling it
it's Sharkboy and Lavagirl and but there
it is but but there's some truth to that
where it's like when you do have total
creative freedom you know again kinda
like with Phantom Menace or something
like that you know it's like you do kind
of need a few people to come in and say
no that I never thought I'd say this but
it either sit there Phantom Menace oh
that's tough check my locker I think is
shorter I you know what I'll say I'll
say Phantom Menace cos is the technicals
on it I can at least get through and
it's for me it's still not the worst of
the prequels that's attack of the clones
yeah I had the Phantom Menace I can get
the vehicles all right there's some cool
sword fights like I love the Texas I
don't know the look at that movie there
is actually more practical effects in it
than people give it credit for it got
more CGI it has more practical effects
in Sharkboy and Lavagirl yeah but it
doesn't have Linus it doesn't have like
Jar Jar and that is a major trade yeah
um
it has JQ also trade down yeah I don't
know I I think the technicals of that
like but that's a case where it's just
like well they had the budget and the
budget made up for the fact that
everything else suck doesn't make
phantom in that's a good movie I've just
done our money remember Phantom Menace
like I don't remember Sharkboy and
Lavagirl but again even though that's
like all a lot of that is CG they're
still trying to make it look like it's
really there you know for the most part
that little cracker thing at the race
wave and that was weird
but like you know but like the cities
and everything the underwater worlds
there trying to really make it look like
you're really there and it looks more
impressive like that where and you get
more of a sense of wonder because you
feel like you're closer to really being
there where with this you know the the
volcanoes and the
cookie lands and stuff like that I mean
none of it looks for something to thus
if an attacker because that's what
that's what the Star Wars movies did
they started up there's a lot more on
location shooting than people realize in
Phantom Menace like there's more
practical effects that they took out the
puppet Yoda but I mean there's more
practical effects in that original kind
of fan of Menace then people really
realize but then when you get into
attack of the clones and Revenge of the
Sith it starts looking more and more cgi
more and more bigger and literally it's
just like well we're just only on a
green screen so it's weird cuz it's like
it just what Spy Kids series did like I
felt like that well it shot up with the
effort of doing practical effects and
shooting on location then it feels less
and less look real well maybe with CT as
well there's no something you need one
shred of reality like an anchor to tie
it together like even for kids like kids
still need that like something that
makes you feel like it's real and
nothing in Sharkboy and Lavagirl felt
real or in spite kids fear it's like the
first one still I'm like if they felt
kind of like real locations there was a
lot of special effects but it like I
don't know I could see kids getting more
wrapped up and then from apparently what
everybody's saying kids were wrapped up
in Spy Kids and that's why they hate
spike in Surrey and Sharkboy and
Lavagirl because they grew up they were
just like garbage sister so how is it I
can't I can't gauge I can't gauge what
people I think they see Sharkboy and
Lavagirl kinda like Saved by the Bell
where they liked it when they were
younger and then with a gay older
they're like okay this is stupid but I
still kind of loving it so tell us in
the comments the people that talk
commented to me over the years we're all
just like I like like the first movie
and then they just got off when we're
done I hate it can sure cry Lavagirl
sucks like if the idea was they liked
spike kids and then this was garbage so
I don't know I I don't if I got a lot of
comments my boy I used to love this
movie now I realize it's trash or a
couple I bet the people at Ella the
people have recommended it said the same
thing like you gotta do sugar playing
Lavagirl because I love spike kids and
then they just got yeah that's all the
comments like but then the comments I
saw like when I posted it we're saying
like man I used to really like this and
now I don't really that much and then
like no you know what this is still cool
come on leave it alone so I'm a little
curious to yeah let us know what you
think about it you know
now I'm curious that this is still like
have you liked it that's fine I don't
know yeah are you the audience I think
is five year old yeah and there's
lessons or anything like that and I'm
not even hyperbolae Xing like ode cuz
it's so stupid I mean I literally think
he made it for like five to seven eight
if anything when he tries to grow it up
with like the parents possibly going
through a divorce and stuffing then
that's where it gets really dumb it's
like wine Sharkboy and Lavagirl yeah
it's play fucking et man yeah just just
leave it simple you know if you're gonna
make a dumb movie just make a dumb movie
don't don't try it make it smart like
just with little drops that don't add up
but yeah let us know if you legit what
you think of the movie now because I'm a
little curious about that too I'm
curious what the reaction is so people
who like it on ironically yeah that's
sort of a question yeah we don't like it
on ironically I'd be curious about that
don't tell us actually yeah that might
put you want to watch it colorful and
you know keV imaginative but it's like
yeah I'd be curious that someone at you
if you said I like it ironically it's so
bad it's kind of like I kept that yeah
that ironically I had like I tried to be
like whoever is entitled to their
opinion them just like but but but yeah
there's no band lesson said or anything
no I I mean there were so there's kids
but ya know it's just it's mostly I
guess that's why I didn't want to even
review because I'm it's mostly harmless
it's made for five-year-old so you can't
really get bad yeah nobody like who
cares
yeah good the movies called Sharkboy and
Lavagirl what did you think was gonna
happen
yeah so uh yeah that's about it still
love Rodriguez I'm I'm excited for
battle eh oh I think I'm like the only
one everyone else is like oh the eyes
that I don't want but like I think it
looks kinda like Robert Rodriguez I have
concerns I think that thing is good it's
the only anime that managed one of the
few
that's managed to escape not getting
disengaged by AV but Thursday what to do
then um I'm excited I figured I don't
want to like I hope it's good cuz I
don't want to go in and hate it so but
the trailer made me nervous so I'm like
I'm hoping this like well maybe it's a
crappy trailer maybe so but I don't like
Sin City - and nobody else did so yes
sure you are the only way I don't get it
I love it I just love it
I'll probably watch it again this
weekend but yeah so there it is Sharkboy
and Lavagirl let us know if you still
like away your thoughts are and we will
see you next time bye please do not
include a plot summary I'm not going to
read it
I will that's such a lie
you